he's got that in his game though not  only does he have the three ball trio  but he can get in the paint with that  floater heroes jumper from 20 still if  he'd have missed three of their first  four shots neither team is turns it over  you're 0 for 3 couple two shots 5 points  for the rookie Anakin tre young their  primary ball handlers had nine and then  each turnovers respectively in his first  two games  [Applause]  and this can grill threes and they're  both seven feet taller or boy hero again  [Applause]  perfect for afor she locks have made six  of their first eight shots here he is  again now not too hard to find your hero  so far 14 points